current relationship status still single
thank all the ladies of bachelor nation
is stepping out for a single girls night
out in Los Angeles for the Vanderpump
Dogg Foundation's annual gala I love
seeing the sisterhood of bachelor ladies
that's like those are the best
relationships the most long-lasting
relations that come out of that show
will we see any of you at winter games
[Music]
you're giving me the most to work with
but you'll be watching if you're not
there Samantha you've been through a lot
on the show when you look at your
experience when you're raising two
little girls would you let them go into
the show I would it just because I feel
like it was such a good experience even
though you know their relationships
ended up working out there's like so
many cool opportunities that it comes
with it so many good friendships it's
just a cool experience so I'm really
grateful for it I'd let them do it
oh yeah that's your real life you don't
sit there and talk about your family all
the time when you're on the show like
multiple times a day you have to sit
down and like talk about how you feel
and I
exactly it makes you very vulnerable you
better communicator - yeah when you're
used to talking about your feelings and
expressing yourself like you develop
that skill you harness that and it makes
other relationships flow better in the
future
[Music]
you